quoi la mecque pour toi non j'ai pas le
temps le film s'appelle otis sa mère a
disparu
oui alors et alors j'ai un rendez vous à
14 heures il faut que j'aille pour le
pôle travail donc je voulais c'est
puisque la mère a disparu
quoi tu me reconnais pas en fait si
c'était
[Musique]
j'étais coupé les cheveux te une couleur
non non non tu te rappelles pas de mon
prénom redit le première lettre mais li
na li la 405 bleus
[Musique]
la veille me quoi comme essence la moins
chère d'accord oui pas mal mais chez moi
[Musique]
prenant
d'habitude je mets des coûts d'un
réservoir ça marche mais voilà vous avez
quoi comme essence la moins chère
d'accord oui pas mal mais chez moi
[Musique]
prennent au bon moment moi je vais
bosser l'as guémar tu vas te [ __ ] dans
le canapé et tu veux regarder des
dessins ne sais quoi ça tient
ok on va sonner ils vont ouvrir alors
qu'arte c'est quoi ton excuses
aujourd'hui c'est de montrer sans
vieillit mais ça va pas la tête de dire
d'être comme ça on a dit que c'était
fini cette boulette veulent donc là
c'est important les câlins et ben pour
lui les commentaires on ne s'est pas
créé chez mais vous faites enfants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu restes là pas bougé tu as tort moi je
suis un ami de prune toi t'es qui là
super je m'en fous je réponds moi c'est
ce que je veux c'est mon frère ok
d'accord
vous êtes tous frères et ça en fait
vous êtes juste 3 où il y en a d'autres
[Musique]